i am ernest teen shepherd
80 years of age
[Music]
i bench pressed 110
pounds
i started training at age 71.
i was named the oldest female
competitive bodybuilder at the guinness
book of world records
my sister and i started exercising
together
i had never done any type of exercising
before
before she died she said promise me you
will follow my dream and try to get in
the guinness book of world records
so
that's what i did
[Music]
i have been in
six or seven competitions i win
but some i come out second and third and
i'm pleased with that
[Music]
i'm up every morning at 2 30. after i
have my devotions i walk and i run
approximately 10 miles
i'm at the gym at 7 30 and i have a
group of ladies that i train
down
one i train all ages
one of the youngest i think she's about
20 years of age
and the rest go from
40
all the way up to
80.
when people come to my class for the
very first time
they are really
really surprised
they said i didn't think this exercise
would be this tough
but if you can do it we are going to do
it too
i really don't feel as though i'm 80
years of age but i am
i want to keep training until
my day is done
[Music]
you